in question one in question in question
one you see how they've got sentences
and then we created excuse me
we created an equation right so they're
asking us to go in reverse order
if you've got given this what sentence
could you craft it's going to sound like
the sentences in question one that would
be equivalent to that I'll give you a
hint I guess I would start with the
letter S yes very good yeah that is
pretty much perfect okay because you can
see there's x-cubed
there's s and the proportionality which
they this is the other question they're
asking yes right the constant of
variation that controls the
proportionality what's the number have a
look it's to you know it's the constant
because no matter what s or X you put
into their two stays the same every
single equation always has two so you
would say K equals to dance keys if you
were to have a look at puppy it is a
fraction that's okay let's start off
with the bit that we know right we would
say what's the first variable T varies
directly as what look at the previous
question we did look in question one T
varies directly as the square root of L
now what's K now this is sneaky it's
just thinking have a look at the way
we've written every single variation
question on the board sorry every single
variation equation on the board I'm
gonna highlight them for you I haven't
used I haven't used blue yet it's
amazing okay here we go here here here
here have a look the fractions
every time K is multiplied by the other
thing K is multiplied by the other thing
etc so in this equation what is the
equation T we need to come up with a way
to write this so it is something times
the square root of L so what can we put
in its place
how can you turn to vision into
multiplication you could do that what
would that be dividing by 5 would be be
0.2 right so this is the same as
multiplying by 0.2 I would probably say
that's fine by the way K is 0.2 I'm you
didn't have to go to a decimal you can
just say that it's a few that a fifth
and zero point you same deal yeah so in
this case k is not 5 K is 1 over 5 and
that's what gives the fraction okay